(upbeat music)
- Oh my god.
It's the intro.
This is so exciting.
Oh, hi, I'm Megan and
recently I completed six items
off my bucket list in six days.
And now I just want to give
someone else the opportunity
to live their best lives.
The point isn't to
complete your bucket list.
It's just to get a running start.
This week we're gonna go on an
adventure with Ryann Graham.
He's a video producer here at BuzzFeed
and the most joyful, smiliest
person you will ever meet.
Come on in, Ryann.
- Aw, That was really nice.
I didn't know what you were gonna say.
Did you put your feet in this?
- Not all of 'em.
So, if you were to cross off three things
from your bucket list, what would they be?
- First, I would love to go drag racing.
I'm a bit of a control
freak so it would be
really hard for me to
be in a passenger seat
going 100 miles an hour and
just trusting and letting go.
The second thing I want to do is stay
in an actual haunted
house, but I think there's
something about being
in something that has
actually experienced
tragedy or something scary.
Like, I don't know.
Could you imagine being
taken over by a ghost?
- I prefer not to.
- My third thing, not to be
confused with drag racing,
is to dress and perform in drag.
That's probably my ultimate
bucket list item, honestly.
- I mean, if you're not busy this week
I think we can make that happen.
- Really?
- Drag racing tomorrow?
- Oh, tomorrow?
But we have to finish all these first?
- Oh, yeah, they were very expensive.
- Alright.
More fries.
(upbeat music)
- What a beautiful day to
scare the shit outta Ryann.
Today we're at Exotic Racing in Montana
where Ryann with be in the passenger seat
of a vehicle going over
125 miles per hour.
But what he doesn't know
is when he's gonna be taking off.
So, I've told the driver
to basically pretend
like he's gonna take some
time to show him the buttons.
Let me show you what these
things do, and then boom.
He's gonna take off, scare
the shit out of Ryann.
'Cause that's what this
is all about, right?
Right?
Why is this on your bucket list and
why must you do this before you die?
- I'm a little bit of a control freak.
After today, I'm hoping that
this feeling of letting go
and trusting bleeds into
other areas of my life.
I don't know.
It'll be fun or I'll die.
Either way, what's the
worst that could happen?
Stop, you're making me nervous.
Stop it, Megan.
- Let's do it.
- Alright, let's go.
- Do people crash?
- You know, if I told you no I'd be lying.
You ready?
- As ready as I'll ever be.
- So, what we have here in front
of us is a 1.2 mile road course.
- I thought it was gonna be straight away.
- Not at all.
- Whoa!
Okay. Okay.
Okay, okay.
Holy crap!
Oh my god.
I got this. I got this.
- Hang on. Hang on.
- Whoa, we're not, holy shit!
Oh, this is so fun, but so scary.
Oh my god, we're going like 120, 130?
(screams)
(car horn honks)
(Megan laughs)
- [Megan] He looked horrified.
(camera shutter clicks)
- What did ya think, Ryann?
- That was so fun.
Holy crap, wow!
This was like this coolest thing
I think I've ever done in my life.
It was such a freeing experience.
I had to just be in the
car and let it happen.
But if that's how day one was
I can only imagine how day two
and day three are gonna be.
Thank you so much.
- Of course.
Let's go on to day two.
Let's go!
Take the helmet, just take it.
So, Ryann is really jazzed
to stay somewhere haunted tonight,
but what he doesn't know
is that I've booked us
the most notoriously haunted room
in the most notoriously
haunted boat in America.
The Queen Mary.
- Are we ready to go yet?
- Yep.
- [Megan] Alright, take a step
up, up, yep, there you go.
Do you remember saying that being
afraid made you feel alive?
- Yeah.
- That's what you're
looking for?
- Yes.
- Yeah, okay, just remember that.
- Holy crap.
That's the Queen Mary.
- Why is this on your bucket list?
Why do you want to be haunted so bad?
- Something about being around
ghosts and being scared,
that fear is like so thrilling
that it makes you feel alive.
Part of me hopes you get
possessed so I can be like.
That way I can interact.
- Let's just go take the tour.
- My name is Commodore Everette Hoard.
This ship carried 2.5 million
passengers back and forth
across the Atlantic, in war, in peace.
A lot of those guys that went over
on this ship did not come home.
Some of their last memories were scratched
into the hand rails all the
way around the top of the ship.
- I don't like that.
I don't like any of this.
- This ship has a wonderful,
happy presence about it,
and a lot of people do have experiences.
I hear people talk.
I heard one speak in 2011.
- What did they say to you?
- She said, "I'm so cold.
"I'm so very cold."
- Did you get her a blanket?
- [Commodore] We're
gonna go to cabin B340.
- [Megan] That's where
we're sleeping tonight.
- Oh, good.
If there's anything that will happen,
it'll be in B340.
We're going further and
further beneath the sea, now.
- [Ryann] I don't like this.
Are you doing that on purpose?
- [Camera Man] Oh I don't know.
But I was getting a strobing effect
on my camera too and I was just like--
- [Camera Man] Yeah, I didn't
realize that's what it was.
- [Ryann] Ooo, was that
doing that upstairs?
- [Camera Man] No.
It was just happening by that thing.
- So, you wouldn't stay in this room
is what you're telling me.
- No.
When I would go in there,
there were so many reports
of incidents happening in the cabin
that they finally stopped
renting it out to people.
People had reported
lights turning on and off,
water starting, water stopping.
- No, no, no.
- Oh, did you hear that?
What is that?
- [Megan] Don't. (laughs)
- No.
(Megan screams)
- Oh my god, Everette did it.
(laughing)
- The thing is neither of us
tried to protect each other.
Is there a number to
call if anything happens?
- Not mine.
- Alright, let's go in.
- Okay, um...
- Oh, you're gonna go in there right now?
- Yeah.
- I'm needed on the bridge.
- Okay, bye.
- Ooh, I don't like this.
Oh, okay, okay.
It's just a little creepy.
Oh, that can't be a thing.
That freaked me out.
Is this, okay, I feel
like I can stay here.
It don't smell like new.
It smell like death.
- [Megan] What are those doors?
- I don't know.
See now, if something pops
out at me, I swear to god.
- [Megan] This is just
a (gasps) oh my god.
See.
- I didn't know.
I didn't know what was gonna be in there.
- What?
- No, that was a real noise.
Hold on.
Cause it like, it came from over here.
You mean you don't hear
that like knocking?
Megan, stop playing.
No, literally.
Wait, wait, wait.
Okay, maybe, I swear I heard a knock.
- If you fall asleep I'm waking you up.
- Okay, this is home.
This is gonna be home.
- I hate you.
- Alright, crew, so it's
just gonna be me and Megan.
- And the ghosts.
- And the ghosts, and all the ghosts.
Like review the footage immediately.
- But don't tell us what you saw.
- Oh my god, no, tell me.
Let's do this.
- [Megan] Do we have to sit on the floor?
- Yeah, what?
You can't do this on the bed.
- [Megan] The floor feels dangerous.
- Come on.
Is anyone in this room with us?
I hate you, I hate you,
I hate you, I hate you.
- I think you're moving it.
- Are you gonna scare us tonight?
What? Look at you.
(both laughing)
- Dear ghostie, are you
living a happy life?
- Stop.
You're doing that.
- You're doing that.
You, stop.
You know you're doing that.
- I'm not doing that.
Oh my god.
We're done.
For my mental health we're
keeping the light on.
- Let's do this.
- Okay, good night.
- Good night.
(suspenseful music)
- What is it?
- [Megan] I want to scare them.
(knocking at door)
(rapping at door)
Yeah, I think I scared
the shit outta them.
- It's funny 'cause we
thought we were gonna
find ghosts, but we end up
becoming the ghosts instead.
I slept surprisingly well.
It was cool to get to be here
and have those moments
of fear and just like
get over and conquer it.
- I'm really glad that
you're getting to check
this off your bucket
list and I'm really glad
that I never have to come here again.
So, today Ryann is being
transformed into a drag queen,
but what I haven't told him is
that he's gonna perform for
all of our coworkers tomorrow.
But we'll tell him that later.
Alright, Ryann, I've
brought in the one and only,
most wonderful LA queen.
- Anita Procedure!
Hi!
- Hey, how are you?
- Oh, it's so good to meet you, Ryann.
- It's good to meet you.
- Hi, darling.
- Cause I feel like
there's so much confidence
- 'Cause I feel like
you have to have when
you're performing drag
and being a drag queen, and I feel like
I don't know if I necessarily have.
I was closeted for so long in my life
that it's a part of me that I feel like
I want to explore and push more.
- Today is part of your drag training.
We are going to be going
over walking in heels,
We are gonna be going
for your performance tomorrow.
- My performance?
- I'll leave you guys to it.
- It's gonna be great.
It's a little kick ball change.
It's a little one two step in
front of your coworker, okay?
front of your coworkers, okay?
- Alright, let's get to it.
Let's get rehearsing, honey.
Custom made from Milan.
- I've never like walked walked in heels.
Target.
- Let's go for it.
Let's do a little strut.
Don't look down, don't look down.
- Oh okay.
- Don't second guess it.
(upbeat music)
Yes, bitch.
Don't take out the equipment, girl.
Give it to them.
Yes, bitch.
Keep going.
I did not tell you to stop.
Okay, so now that you are armed
with all the knowledge you
need to pound a runway, honey.
We gotta get you an outfit, girl.
So, let's take a look at our
beautiful rack of clothing
that are definitely not from Goodwill
and see what we can find you.
(bright music)
Bring it in.
- Okay.
- Hit me.
Move that bus.
- Is this it?
- Oh, bitch, that one is it.
- This is gonna be the perfect outfit
for drag queen Ryann.
- It's got your essence.
- Yes. It does.
The only thing I'm
worried about there's just
a whole lot of...
- A little too much essence.
- Yes.
- We are gonna teach
you about tucking, girl.
Come with me, come on.
- Okay.
Okay, so how does this work?
- [Anita] Basically, you wanna
get your balls in your ass.
- [Ryann] What?
- [Anita] And then your
dick between your ass.
You like, you get in there.
- [Ryann] You get in there.
You listen.
You put that down.
- [Anita] And now you're a lady.
She's tucked and ready.
- Yeah. I feel like a lady.
- Okay, so here we are.
We are in the dance studio.
It's time to go over your
routine for tomorrow.
Yeah, let's play it.
(party music)
Yes, girl, yes.
That's it, okay.
- I'm gonna do it.
- I believe in you.
You're gonna do it, girl.
- Ya'll, it's five p.m.
So, we're gonna take a break,
meet back tomorrow for your performance.
Let's go home.
- Alright, I'm out of here, girl.
Let's go.
- So, I'm here.
I'm ready to get this face beat.
- [Anita] So, we've kind of been
putting together your
look, but how do you feel
about your drag persona,
like what kinda girl is she?
- [Ryann] I want it to be someone
who is very confident and very like...
I mean, I don't want to say like bitchy,
but just like, mmm, just
very I guess fierce.
- [Anita] Are you a good
bitch or a bad bitch?
- [Ryann] Somewhere in between.
(party music)
Okay, eyes are officially closed.
- [Megan] Keep your eyes closed.
- Okay, they're closed.
- Stay there.
- Okay.
- I'm like shaking.
- [Megan] Alright, open 'em.
- Oh my...
(laughs) Yes!
Wow.
Ooh, yes.
I do look wealthy I'm not gonna lie.
I look fucking good.
(party music)
- I know it's me, but this
is like another side of me.
This is Samore.
This is Samore Dollahz, honey.
- [Megan] Is that your drag name?
- Yes. Samore Dollahz.
It came to me in a dream last night.
She's quite wealthy if you didn't know.
She bought this fur just to throw it away.
I am ready to go perform for my coworkers.
I'm gonna go serve the children,
feed them, bless them, really.
(party music)
- Hello, hello, hello, BuzzFeed.
How ya'll doing?
(audience shouts)
Oh, yeah, don't be shy around me.
- How're you feeling
- I'm so nervous but also so excited.
- Good luck.
- I've had the privilege
of transforming Ryann
into a motherfucking drag queen, ya'll.
(audience shouts)
It has been so much fun.
So, this is one of the
things on his bucket list,
and I am so excited to announce
the world wide premiere
of his new persona, Samore Dollahz.
(audience shouts)
(cash register bell dings)
(techno music)
(audience shouts)
♪ Girls on top ♪
♪ Looking hot ♪
♪ Hot hot hot hot ♪
♪ Ooh, tease ♪
♪ Text me ♪
♪ Watch me dance ♪
♪ Watch me move ♪
♪ Push me under ♪
♪ Feel the truth ♪
♪ Higher, higher ♪
♪ Keep just moving higher, higher ♪
♪ Tell me, higher, higher ♪
♪ Keep it moving higher ♪
(audience shouts and applauds)
- [Anita] Work bitch.
Work, work, work, work, work.
- This was one of the coolest things
I've ever done in my life.
I feel like I can do anything.
Like I'm on top of the world.
I feel like I can go on
and live my best self
from here on out.
I'm so happy.
Thank you so much.
- Yay! I'm so glad.
Alright, well, go do it.
Go live your best life.
- [Ryann] Okay.
- [Megan] Wait, wait, come back.
(record scratches)
There's a million other people who haven't
even started their bucket list.
And I'm gonna go find them.
We've more work to do people.
(upbeat music)